ou de l'ministre de la sécurité
publique.
- Tôt dimanche matin, cet avis
a été distribué aux camionneurs
garés devant le Parlement.
Les policiers ne les toléreront
ncore longtemps sur
le boulevard René-Lévesque.
- C'est le dernier avis,
c'est bon?
C'est compris pour vous aussi?
Merci beaucoup, Messieurs.
- Les agents sont déployés en
grand nombre. Prochaine étape :
les contraventions. Juste
avant de se faire remorquer,
ce manifestant en camionnette
quitte de son plein gré.
- Ça a super bien été.
Les policiers étaient vraiment
gentils avec nous autres.
Ils étaient conciliants.
- Les camionneurs aussi l'ont
été. Ils ont attendu à 10 h 30
pour commencer à klaxonner.
(klaxons)
- On est tous ensemble
là-dedans!
- Des sympathisants du mouvement
ont construit cette cabane
à café.
- C'est notre façon
de contribuer nous aussi!
- D'autres essayent d'amuser
la foule pour la garder
sur place plus longtemps.
Mê plupart
des camionneurs sont équipés
pour rester, leur réalité
réalité quotidienne
les rattrape.
- On pense peut-être partir
aujourd'hui, nous autres,
parce que, ma blonde,
elle travaille demain, là.
- Bien moi, faut que je reprenne
la route aujourd'hui.
- Faut comprendre qu'il y a
des gars aussi là-dedans
qui travaillent. Il y a
des familles. On est du mo
ordinaire, comme tout le monde.
BERNARD GAUTHIER, représentant
syndical
- On nous a demandé
de manifester pacifiquem
et c'est ce qu'on a fait.
Astheure, on s'attend
à un retour d'ascenceur.
- (en choeur:) Liberté! Liberté!
- Les organisateurs, qui veulent
la levée des mesures sanitaires,
promettent de revenir.
- Ça fait qu'on se redonne
rendez-vous dans deux semaines.
On va refaire la même affairequa
être beaucoup plus nombreux.
- C'est certain, certain qu'on
revient dans deux semaines, oui!
- Je vais revenir tant
que çatera pas!tera pas!tera pa!
- Personne voulait de
débordement ici et il n'y en a
pas eu! Fait que, ça prouve
que le monde est civilisé.
- Les manifestants disent
repartir la tête haute,
sans avoir dérangé les résidents
du Vieux-Québec ni compromis
l'ouverture du Carnaval.
Ils espèrent que leur messagea,
qui ont tous choisi,
sans exception, de ne pas
venir à leur rencontre.
Ici V